hey everyone it's joanna here are you
excited for another indoor walking
challenge
and this time i have husley here with me
hi guys sir hazle is a really great
group instructor and he is amazing when
it comes to music based workouts so haas
what are we doing today all right so for
today we will be giving you a workout to
help you hit 5 000 steps in the comfort
of your own home yep and it will be
music based so it's going to be really
fun we're going to be following the
beats and so our goal for this next 30
days is to achieve
150 000 steps sounds a lot sounds a lot
but if you do it every day and just have
fun with it you'll get there yep so
don't worry if you can't follow the
steps don't worry if you mess it up
because i know i am what's most
important is that we have fun yep very
true so let's start
walking let's go
all right guys we're gonna start off
with a basic warm-up begin health first
up
and four basic steps
to start off the walking ready guys
all right guys march
there we go so this is your first basic
movement which is the march so any time
when i spring march we're coming back to
this basic yes
[Music]
and stay up
good good good
the journey has begun and you're already
walking up
five thousand steps here we come
higher higher higher up
after this i'll be showing you a new
movement called step touch base number
two yup much
calm down four
three step touch now hit
hope go boom
[Music]
nice
got it got it got it so hydrate is
coming up yes
can we add on the arm boom
nice one
looking again
mirror image so just follow me like
you're looking in the mirror
four
three
match it out right now
next i'm going to show you how we combo
these two things together and layer them
up yep
three march in here hold
four
three
two step touch now arms in arms in
and much out
touch
boom
mush it up match it out all right guys
next new movement next
soft kicks yup
keeping it low
and just soft
stand by four
three stop kick rip
boom
nice
ooh jordan are not bad good having fun
just having fun with the music
i want to add the arms imagine you're
going to do a bicep curl yes let's add
on
up
hey
moving that whole body getting your
cardio up
are you ready to combo this
ready guys just match it out right now
taking it easy here
we're going to repeat that same thing
i'm going to combo it okay
big inhale first
and down
stay here stay here guys up
so you got three basics down
and we're going to go with the combo
out
up
out
guys big match now hit
hit
step touch now hit
good arms
[Music]
guys in four three soft kicks to the
front
kick
good can we combo everything
you have donor try my best let's do it
bicep curl
stand by guys four
three
two much stay small small hit go boom
[Music]
touch [ __ ]
arms
and kicks arms curl
stay here stay here
guys come back to your match right
now
step touch with arms step touch step
touch kick with curls kick
kick
stay here
[Music]
match it out match it out
next one we have a new move coming up
yes gang the final basic move is the
knees
yep because throughout this whole
walking journey these basic stuff will
come back each and every time
[Music]
much
stay with me
ready for the knees and four
three
knees up
one
one now you can add the arm with a
slight rotate yes
so we get the core involved as well
smaller crunchier i'm ready to combo
everything joanna yeah i am ready combo
do it
match
step touch
in out
kick
one
two and knees
yeah
you got it smash it out
step touch right now
arms out arms out
kicks
if you make a mistake it's fine right
just human knees
[Music]
much
[Music]
and stay
good guys that's your one full warm up
and we are walking yep so are we ready
to go to the next level joanna i am all
right so basically remember these basics
but now i'm going to take you around the
room we'll be traveling forward left and
right
yep are you okay with this right now
let's do it
all right guys pick it up
boom
stay
we're gonna travel yes stay with me
oh
stand by
four
three
come to the front go
and back
again again so this time with the basic
stuff you just learned i'm going to take
you around the room
one more time
guys just side turn around go
and come back stay go on front again
yes
nice one guys
last one and then we're gonna go the
other side yep
back go
[Applause]
remember your combo from the first track
just now
we're gonna go back to that
one more
guys
center
match
step touch
and kicks one kick two kick and then
knees
much one two three step
got it
kick so basics
knees let's try to get joanna march it
out step touch
kick
and knees why am i doing this because
we're going to be doing this later while
traveling
getting that basics in purse
okay match it out
watch it out
got it recall it
this time we're gonna use that same
combo but travel
sounds difficult right yeah but i'm
gonna fall okay
yep
two
normal travels normal travel
clap normal travel just stay here
stay
go
[Applause]
match it out
okay it's coming the big trouble
[Music]
standby guys four
two
forward
and step watch
kick one kick one kick two knees
yes walk forward
step touch
kicks
boom oh jordan are doing good
forward
step two
kick
yes knees and stay here match it up here
good match it out stay here hold you got
it
got it
and let's go with the big one four
three come to me pick one
and step touch with the arms if you want
yeah curl
curl and up come forward
step touch forward forward kick up pump
pop
again
nice whoa
lift and up
who knew walking could be this one
and again
no you're doing good
kick
up and up go again
all right now guys stay here and we're
just gonna travel and clap come on
travel
and clap
and clap good
[Applause]
nice
stay
and much
good i am sweating i am sweating
good that's what we want
next one something a little bit more
fitness based it's like a squat and a
lunge forward lunge but we're just going
to keep it at maybe 30 of the normal
range yeah ah shake it off shake it up
guys do you know what has we have
achieved one kilometers more than that i
know wow
amazing nice in the comfort of your own
home amazing
all right guys
step out your legs here
guys open close this leg
one and in so soft knees and come back
so we're gonna switch to this side and
this side
yes
so it's just like getting into a stance
or squat but soft underneath and just a
little hinge but that's it
now can we commit to this down
up
down
up good
nice gang
all right guys the music is coming up it
means
faster faster hit
boom
boom
yes
step
step so remember you don't have to go
down too low like the normal squat yeah
guys check this out alternating lunge
forward small steps to the front step
step yes so soft knees only up
[Music]
this is fun the next round we're going
to combo this yep
hold and then inhale
and then down good good
keep on marching because we're still
walking
imagine outside just taking a breeze
and then from the start
open open step
you got it
so this round we're going to combo
things so it's going to be a little bit
different yeah
all right watch this one
stay here first same thing
two squats two forward lunge in
this side and to the front
one
yeah so you see what i'm doing right
here
giving you the basic and layering it up
for you so that we know what's coming up
next a combo
boom
let's commit to it a little bit more
since you know the movement and when the
music goes faster you know what to do
yes
i think we know what to do right now
let's speed it up speed it up
speed it up hit hit now step
step and down
down pull
and reach
reach so out
out
forward forward
guys we're still here still here go
go
forward and change
step
step
i think we've walked a long way
ah
guys just the lunges
finish it off
with a little stomp and a stomp
i'm getting into it gang
boom
nice
we're almost halfway through this whole
thing yes
mash it off
ah
so like i just chased
i've just been chased by embarrassing i
can't even talk right now if you think
that's to buy a bear be ready to run
from a tiger next yeah because we're
gonna have some jumping jacks here take
it easy yeah so remember if jumping
jacks is too much for you
remember to just step
okay
match it out one
nope
stay with me
new move side tab
check this tab
yes so we're going to combo the match
and the side tap next yep
four
three
match and tap good
reach with the arms tap
tap and match
got it
again
can we pick this up joanna
we're gonna pick it up guys jog and
jumping jack
job
jumping jack
[Music]
again
mash it
out got it yep got it so she said she
was chased by a bear i think this is a
tiger right now
much
just take it easy here guys don't worry
i'm gonna pick you up again yep
simple
there we go
okay we're going to do a small combo
easy one yes
small little match
and small little tap oh
oh
because you're gonna bring the arm up
next yes
last one then we take it up
four three two watch
take the arms up
nice
are you ready to jog and jump joanna yes
i am if not guys
let's go let's go up
[Music]
one more
match it out
[Music]
oh good
good job good job
all right guys next one
grapevine
you know this one right i know this one
you know this one lots of times
[Music]
stay here
[Music]
check this out simple grapevine one step
in
yes got it it's open cross open cool
tap
good
i'm gonna teach you a new move in a bit
last two
last one come back to the center heel
tab watch
yeah as we go
so we're gonna see a new combo coming up
next yeah
four
three guys watch this combo grab bind
this side
tap it forward tap
tap this side
this leg
always start with this leg yes when we
come forward
[Music]
and stay here much
good you got that movement yes next
we're gonna travel
but i'm gonna give you a new move next
and we're gonna lay it even more
four
three
grapevine right now
and tap
good we're going to switch the tap next
to a heel dig fast one yep so you're
gonna see it next yeah
gravine
guys this side and heel dig fast go one
two and dig forward dig dig dig go nice
oh joanna amazing
good yep
dig
and go this time we're going to go back
here but the heel dig is going to
transform to shuffle
in
and shuffle
nice
in out in out
having fun with this music and having
fun with this movement
nice take it in
and mash it off
so fast
you guys are doing great yes stay with
me here
[Music]
four
three tap slow
and relax
okay guys
okay
now we're gonna be traveling forward yup
much
[Music]
watch this tap
tap just watch this
come back
[Music]
four times to the front go
go back
go
forward
and back
[Music]
good
[Music]
now we're going to take our arms up and
travel yeah
up
up
up
up and come back up
up
nice and again
to the front step
good i'm gonna change this a little bit
both arms
up one up one up and we're going to go
down go down
down and step
travel and up
forward
forward
forward and tap down
good job gang
match it out
got it trying to be as graceful as i can
yeah yeah
guys no matter what you're getting your
steps
and enjoy the music
four
three
two travel forward tap
and back
forward
much
good you know what's gonna happen next
we're gonna fly yep and then we're gonna
fly
down yep
[Music]
are you ready for this right now i am
yep
calm down coming up
four
three
two
one hit up up oh
i made a mistake
but it's fine come on down
and again forward take it up one arm
only first
and come back guys we're gonna go double
arm now
and
down up
[Music]
take it down
down
down
take it up
[Music]
and stick it down
can we match it off pick it up
ah
good gosh
next we have v-step yeah vista that's my
favorite actually
i'm gonna give it a little twist right
now okay
let's be i'm ready for the twist
hmm
we're gonna check it out
stay here
four
three
two three step watch this
one two in
one two this is called a v step gang yes
again so i'm gonna play with a little
bit of a levels here so we're gonna go
lower v step four
three
two lower lower
down down up so you get the glutes
working when you come up here yep
nice
have you heard of a mambo joanna
well i'm going to three
two mambo check this out one mambo step
one
this is a mambo guys so we're going to
combo the v-step and the mambo next
look at joanna
just swinging my head
march it out
so we can combo this next yeah try and
mambo
v step mambo guys guys
that's the combo
[Music]
[Music]
baby coming up gang
hold one
two
in
in go again
so we're gonna pick it up next
fast yep
and we're going to combine this
with the mambo as well fast go
mambo
v-step again oh my gosh boom boom this
side
yes step
this side
mambo v step
lower
and mumbo with the arms reset
mambo here with the arms this step
this side
arms come down
this step only
[Music]
nice
open
show me that hip hip
hip hip
and much
not bad
so mambo is a new thing for joanna
definitely yeah we gotta work on the
arms now yep cool
all right guys easy much
take it in here
we're gonna be traveling a little bit
this time again yes
guys
i'm
open hey
give me some attitude joanna
all right
[Music]
stay
down
one two
step
step so look at the toe so
so
now let's work on your isometric hold
arms go
stay
look at this you don't get to see joey
and i do this a lot i'm working on my
hips and my core
guys
travel forward remember this
basic and then
cross
cross
cross take it forward
and cross forward with the light kick
yes that's the basic that's why we learn
all the basics to take ourselves here
and
kick forward cross
cross
fly forward
joe and i'm so cute
forward
guys
tap
out
like a wave
wave
[Music]
i can't stop laughing you know kid
tap
tap
hey
i'm having fun here watching joanna as
well
if jonah can do it you guys can do it i
know if i can do it you can do it at
home hey
reach you switch tap
remember to travel and the cross forward
this time we add a little crumb to it
yes when you cross we go boom yeah
slow travel try
and kick
kick
kick
hold come forward
[Music]
boom
boom
yeah
hit
boom
boom
galloping back
nice the end up stop it step it up
kick it back
forward
and kick it back
releasing it out and forward
nice and relax
up
[Applause]
and out
in
we're done with this strike i love this
track actually
we're coming to the very end soon
all right guys check it out
how much have we done
i've gotten
four thousand plus right guys this is
your last track this is our last track
and we're going to run to the finish
line not really run
but
we're technically going to jog
jog
[Music]
yes
this strong final track let's go
[Music]
four three single single knee
[Music]
give it
give it to me
we're gonna shift this double knees
right now
we're going to go double knee and travel
forward yes jog forward
[Music]
stand by guys four
and double knee jog to the front
and jack
run back
and jack front
up
check
jog back
and stay here
stay here
got it
squeeze all the steps in
four
three single single knee
okay joiner yes all good
all the combos
[Music]
four three
double knee
hey
[Music]
i'm gonna try and travel but we're gonna
keep it simple yeah
so i'm gonna take off the jumping jacks
this time but just focus on the walk
watch this knee knee knee and walk
much
knee
can walk back
hold
knees
[Music]
walk
hold
knees
are we ready for this
walk back we only go to single knees
go
one and walk
knees
yes and run back
knee
knee run
guys joanna are you ready to travel try
this side yeah good one and run
knees
run back the other side back back back
back
one
two run
ah
come back to the front guys
to stay the knees
[Music]
same thing guys same thing guys
[Music]
double
[Music]
so now we have all the movements in
we're gonna finish this last big round
four
guys double knee and slow travel one two
three come on forward walk hold
double knees
back back back
hold
double knees again
hey
walk
hold up
now we're going to go single knee and
jog ready joanna
four three double knees one inch and
then run forward
knees
and run back this side
knees knees knees run back
knees
jump back switch the other side
knee first
front please
run back finish off
and light one
last last round
finish it off guys strong
you're at your 5 000 mark here yeah
double
ready to take it home joanna i am all
right let's go all out all out
simple travel yes simple travel now go
one two and walk to the front
[Music]
boom stay and double knees one two
and walk back
[Music]
go
forward
double knees
guys final travel throughout the room
[Music]
single single day
jog up
joey i know where to go right yeah
knees look joanna got it
up and walk back yesterday now
[Music]
come forward guys
finish finish strong
jump back one high five
oh this side oh my gosh
i've achieved 5 000 steps that was
amazing us i really enjoyed that so if
you do enjoy my previous walking videos
this is definitely a step up
so much fun
so energetic
and you know what i love it when we're
following the music it's just you know
it's just so much fun yeah yeah it
basically
takes you a bit more easier to finish
the workout yeah it doesn't feel like
working yeah it feels like oh my gosh
what's next and what yeah i mean i'm so
proud of this girl right here
so that's a secret right here okay we
never rehearse
our videos so it is my first time doing
it you know i i can follow the steps so
i'm sure all of you at home can follow
the steps as well and what's most
important is that for you to have fun
get your cardio up and to just burn fat
and sweat it out yes so we hope that you
stick on to this challenge for the next
30 days to get that
150 000 steps at the end of the month
yes and be sure to tag us on ig at
joanna's official at hasley bajilli and
also enjoy this workout share this
workout with your family and friends get
them to join you and don't forget to
also hit the subscribe button let me let
me know in the comments below how you
felt and if you want to see more of this
guy more in a music based workout let us
know and we'll see you next time bye
guys bye bye
sweaty